senators will here for more than two
dozen witnesses today now that the
questioning of Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh is over the Judiciary
Committee argued over confidential
documents released yesterday one was an
email from Cavanaugh his time in the
Bush administration and it raised
questions about whether he really
believes Roe vs. Wade is settled law as
he testified this week this has been
viewed as you saying that you don't
think Roe is settled in that draft
letter it was referring to the views of
legal scholars and I think I think my
comment and email is that might be
overstating the position of legal
scholars and so it wasn't a technically
accurate description Jan Crawford was in
those hearings and joins us now from
Capitol Hill Jan how did that email
impact the questioning of the nominee
and does it have anything to do with his
ultimate confirmation well I I think you
know as you saw there kind of the idea
that there were these confidential
emails actually was more powerful than
the reality I mean what was actually in
them so as you saw in that exchange when
senator Feinstein asked Judge Kavanaugh
he explained he was talking about legal
scholars she said thank you and they
moved on and so I mean I think the
takeaway from that in these last two
days of his testimony is that Democrats
threw a lot of punches but they didn't
really land any you judge Kavanagh has
sat through more than 24 hours in that
hearing what did you learn about how he
prepared for that marathon oh well I
mean John he started preparing for these
hearings basically the next day after he
was nominated just immersing himself in
in the law books in the briefing books
studying the law then starting
questionings with individual lawyers on
various topics all building up to get
this they did four full days of mock
Senate hearings they had 21 lawyers from
inside the White House counsel's office
and outside lawyers playing the various
senators they were timed it was as close
to a real time hearing for four straight
days as you could imagine including
with protesters although I'm told by
White House official they didn't have as
many protesters and the mock hearings as
we saw over the last couple days yeah
unprecedented number of protesters there
or whether they had anybody talking
about Spartacus yes that was probably
not no no not not plan to either Jam
thank you